alright welcome to the star diner how
can I help you I just get a cheeseburger
Oh reliable guy my name is o juice
what kind of know chicks they're getting
pretty tired of vanilla huh maybe you
want to try something a little different
no what if we go off the menu here how
about switch it up a little bit keep
each other guessing yeah like what
I'm so hungry that's my business Connor
let's just get something to eat please
good evening please pull forward and
enjoy our fine dining experience
it's full right overhead they're
enjoying Thank You stranger in a suit
there's a camera on the back did you see
there's there's also camera out there oh
this is everything ok let's go let's go
let's go
please mommy oh my gosh I know you guys
were expecting a difficult drive-through
menu but I hope you don't mind we have
something very different for you Oh for
me that's fancy laughs I hope you be
ready for it something very special
today
oh my god what are these so please grab
it and begin first with a frozen morsel
on top so it's all the traditional
flavors you would find in a strawberry
milkshake but we've done it a little bit
differently we dip it in nitrogen the
outsides crispy and the inside so oh my
gosh we use these modern techniques to
kind of make something a little bit more
exciting than what you're used to it is
the first course
maybe I should slow down there no I'm
jawanda don't have to tell me twice
are you guys ready for the next course
yes all right guys please join us in the
next section okay what's next guys
what's at the next one
I just want to look at this one so when
the spoon is fries that we fried till
they're really crispy and dehydrated and
turns them into a powder and inside the
bottom of the glasses of more grow
Burger foam if you will a spud composers
that's what you are are you ready for
the main course I take a nap first in
Spain we take a siesta oh that's a nice
touch
it's an eyedropper yeah it's an Brigid
is we made a really intense chicken
reduction and so that's what the first
taste we want you to experience in the
little pipette don't judge me you guys
don't like chemist degrees or something
when you have something like spicy or
something open you popplers this you do
I translate oh it's like heaven you're
ready for dessert
oh my gosh it's carrot cake that we've
dehydrated and made into a crumble we
have the carrot raviolis here are the
stuff it with cheese the freshness of
the actual carrot vegetables like it's
the craziest thing is that it's not
crazy it's like all stuff that you know
but like never thought of it like this I
don't know this is you it here I I know
but I don't grow up with that she grew
up with that what a thought we came out
root cheese we got a boy this is like
there's a little step up from the time
you like it back it's all good